[Music]
invisibility is no longer just a topic
of fantasy or science fiction several
companies around the world have
developed technologies to make it a
reality some use a combination of
cameras and digital screens to hide
stationary objects while others offer a
more sophisticated invisibility cloak
type approach but which one works best
how does it harness the power of our
brains and what would our world do with
this powerful ability this is what if
and here's what would happen if you
could make yourself invisible once
perfected invisibility technology will
first be used for military applications
but what will happen when it finally
makes its way to the public well you'd
never be 100% sure you weren't being
watched or followed unless you had an
invisibility cloak of your own in which
case you could probably do just about
anything you wanted without being
detected what would happen to the moral
fabric of society if people were able to
act on their impulses without
consequences
the desire to be invisible has been a
staple of Western culture for millennia
from Plato's Republic right up to modern
science fiction but what does this
desire to become invisible say about us
as a species what is it about
invisibility that we're all so eager to
take advantage of
well before we go down that rabbit hole
let's take a look at how we can make it
a reality after all these years in order
to understand what could make an object
invisible we need to first wrap our
heads around what made it visible in the
first place when you see an object what
you're really seeing is your brains
interpretation of the light that bounces
off of it so in order to make something
invisible all you have to do is disrupt
that process one of the most promising
methods of doing so involves something
called metamaterials
which are human-made materials that can
affect light in ways natural materials
can't if you were to wrap an object in
these materials they could capture light
coming in from one direction and bend it
around the object giving the appearance
that it isn't there at all right now
this technology has only been tested on
tiny objects but one company hyper
stealth claims to have expanded that to
full-on military uniforms that not only
remove your visual and thermal
signatures but also your shadow if these
claims are true and invisibility is
right around the corner what would you
do with it it's funny there are so many
opportunities to help the world with
disability you could become a superhero
of sorts gaining an upper hand on
criminals or you could sneak into closed
quarters to reveal the secrets of
corrupt governments and corporations but
those aren't the first thoughts that
come to the minds of most people when
presented with the prospect of
invisibility instead most people think
of unethical things like scaring people
spying on their crash or stealing things
in fact all you have to do is look at
the anonymity of the Internet to get an
idea of how people would behave if they
were held responsible for their actions
maybe it's a good thing that human
invisibility is still a distant prospect
since being recognized might be the only
thing keeping us in line but that's a
topic for another what-if
[Music]